from screen junk Studios it's time to
tune in to TV fights and now your host
foxy
SRI what's up screen junkies happy
holidays and welcome to TV fights we
have incredible fights today and amazing
Fighters it is the special holiday
episode where we are for free on YouTube
we're also on screen junkies plus where
you can always find us but we are free
on YouTube today this Tuesday at 4 p.m.
uh so make sure you definitely check out
this week's episode we're talking about
the worst TV mom uh the best show of
2015 and of course course the best
Christmas episode of TV of all time
before we talk about our Fighters I want
to make sure you guys know that we have
something going on called GIF Mist so
for a potential oneyear free membership
go to sj.
plusgas and you can fill out a form
there and figure out everything else you
can win uh everything from Kevin Smith
and J M's toys to sign posters and
t-shirts and all that really cool stuff
so definitely make sure you go there
that's sj. plusus GI Miss okay guys we
got these Fighters here today somebody
who I've Loved for a long time he's an
All-Star Survivor player and he hosts a
podcast Rob has a podcast it's Rob Cino
oh thank you thank you very much you
know what we met one time at a podcast
uh award show in Vegas where you won
every single award there it was very
intimidating wow so I believe you're
going to kick butt okay well we'll see
we'll see I don't know about that I
think you'll be okay I believe in you
next fighter you guys have been asking
for him so much and I'm so happy he has
a show on this network called what's in
the buck he also is Jay of Jay and
Silent BB it's Jason Muse hello yeah I
like the wave thank you thank you thanks
for joining us today how you feeling I'm
feeling good I think you made me feel
good you gave me like a pep talk before
we got on here I was like this is going
to be horrible it's the intro music too
it pumps you up a little bit it's
everything it it does okay guys another
person who you've asked for so many
times because he is the champion over at
movie fights he is the co-host of Monday
Night Raw and he's a producer here at
screen junkies it's Dan hi wow I'm out
of my element I'm out of my depth on
this show what is with you guys today
you're all in your element that's why
you're here this is your element I'm
excited though well I'm excited to have
you as always our amazing fact checker
on the couch we've got Ken Napo you're
out of your element Donnie we're out of
it hey it's going to be a fun show as
always I'll be following along with you
at hhtv fights Live join the
conversation there if you say something
fun maybe a little mean and it's still
kind of funny I'll put it on the air I'm
going to try to fact check with these
gentlemen uh try to do a tail of tape
each show but this is kind of wild card
here Dan is new to this Arena but he
knows how to fight Rob C I watched him
on Survivor I was a fan of his work on
Survivor he knows how to get there Works
in politics but can he fight on his feet
and Jason this guy I've seen him fight
Kevin Smith with lightsabers in the
other room man he a little different a
little different words
sa you the lightsaber fight I think so
is different inventiveness so this is
going to be a fun unhinged fight I love
it I I love it too I'm really excited
let's start with this first question for
round
one I want to know what is the best
Christmas episode of TV of course we're
Christmas time right now if you didn't
know that based on my hat and the tinsel
scarf I'm wearing so starting with Rob
then Jason and then Dan what is the best
Christmas episode of TV well I'm going
going to say that it is a Christmas
party from season 2 of the office that
way back in a Time called 2005 that
there was a thing called the office that
we didn't quite know what it was yet and
this was one of the first times that we
really got to fall in love with the
Michael Scott character and find out
about his idio sequencies about how he
really wants to be loved by the people
that he works with so he spends a lot of
money on a Christmas party and he gets a
video iPod in the secret Santa and then
he gets upset because he gets an oven
mitt and so he decides to do a Yankee
Swap which ultimately shows uh his greed
and all these other uh flaws that he has
in his character but for Pam at the end
of the episode she trades in a teapot
for the video iPod Which history has
borne out that the video iPod trade was
a good one for Pam because the video
iPod would be nothing more than a paper
weight now in 2015 and she got a teapot
which was uh given to her by her future
husband Jim so it holds up okay Jason
wow you have years and everything down
man see 10 years um you're like 2005 um
I would say down ABY uh down Abbey for
me was you know there was some the tears
and uh I don't know there was some
surprises there was a marriage proposal
big fan of D and ABY so okay Dan I'm
going with an episode of the westwing
called NX elsis Deo it was their season
one The West Wing had a lot of great
Christmas episodes but this was from the
first season and it's got everything
that I look for it really represents the
Christmas season cuz it's got It's got
some comedy it's got joy it's got
emotion it has a little twinge of
sadness but ultimately it's
inspirational and it has a lot of those
different elements which I can go into a
little bit later on but but just because
it's it's not only a great Christmas
episode but one of the best episodes of
Television that I've ever seen I'm going
with that all right so the office down
to Abby and West Wing let's fight guys
really different ones they are they
couldn't be more different right uh well
I mean just to go into a little bit more
about the the my episode is it's it's
got a bunch of different story lines it
has a really funny storyline where
president Bartlett is looking for uh
Christmas gifts and he goes to this rare
bookstore and he spends his whole time
like just putting out the the wonkiest
dorkiest most obscure books and every
but everyone because he's the president
has to pretend like they're cool so
that's really funny there's a funny bit
where they're signing Christmas cards
but there's this also kind of a a series
storyline where Toby uh is trying to
arrange for a military funeral for this
homeless veteran and so and that ties
into the Christmas season where he's
trying to find his family and it ends
with this great the they're playing The
Little Drummer Boy and it's cutting
between carolers and the White House and
this kind of emotional scene but it is
ultimately uplifting and I think that uh
it kind of has a little bit of
everything Josh and Donna they're kind
of romance bonds he gives her she wants
ski gear and he gives her this book that
has a really heartfelt inscription and
it kind of has all these great different
elements of Christmas in it that really
make you feel good at the end of the
episode is it the kind of thing that you
can get the family around the holidays
and put on the Netflix and sit at them
around to watch westwing this week yeah
I don't know has everything though yours
is comedy though right right comedy his
but I'm digging mine more everybody
everybody can relate to uh the office
down in ABY I think a lot of people are
going to be turned off with the you know
it's period piece not everybody that you
know everybody thinks maybe it's maybe a
little too highbrow for some people N I
don't think so I think I think like
westwing it brings a lot of different
things into it down in Abby because you
have someone accused of murder and then
they surprise he surprises his wife at
the end um and then you have the Butler
and the headid that they propose and
they're going to you know spend the rest
of their life together now we're talking
office here you can't let the kids sit
around the campfire and watch the office
right it's a little naughty business
kids are watching down ABY sure sure why
not there's no cussing or anything
there's some love some cool castles
involved are the kids punished that they
have to watch down Abby maybe maybe some
some I think some will enjoy it so well
yeah for me it's like yes you're not
going to get your six-year-old and sit
down and watch the the West swing but I
agree I'm not going to grab a
six-year-old and put in front of the
office either I'm going to put in front
of the grire you know Santa Claus com to
town or something how about down Abby
though you'd put the six-year-old in
front of that down AB I would put it no
I for me when I was coming out the best
Christmas episode it's what connects to
me personally on a more personal level
and and I I certainly enjoyed the
Downtown Abbey uh Christmas special as
well and and you know it's one of those
fights where it's like I can't really
talk that poorly about either one of
your choices because they're both good
choices I just think that mine again it
has so many different elements of the
holiday season because Christmas Means
the holidays mean you know different
things to different people and it's a
different kind of time and they even
address that with Mrs landingham and the
holidays make her sad because she
remembers her sons and I feel like it
kind of it connects to people in
different ways and it has a lot of those
elements that a lot of people can
identify with instead of maybe you know
just the drama or just the comedy it it
mixes all of them because it has so many
very do that too I want to hear you guys
final thoughts and while you're saying I
want to make sure that you mentioned why
it's the best Christmas episode of TV so
not just the best episode of this uh
show that you're talking about but the
best Christmas episode starting with you
rob well I feel like that it's the best
Christmas episode because it's just so
relatable we've all been in these
horrible office secret Santa at
different points in time and you know
you're going to end up getting something
horrible so you end up really sort of
identifying with the characters in it
but it also has the sweetness of the Jim
and Pam thing which is going to be born
out to be the heart and soul of that
series we don't quite know that yet and
then everything going on with Michael
and the whole video iPod is still uh
really holds up to this day okay Jason I
think uh down and Abby because you know
it's again it's the familes getting
together they they let the uh the driver
like he married the daughter and they
let him in there for Christmas and he
has his daughter and they took him in
anyway then uh the husband doesn't go to
jail and he comes and surprises the wife
they're singing carols at the end and
there's like the whole surprise um um
and so there's a lot of elements there
that I I I feel that brought a little
tear to my eye and happiness and joy
sure and and for mine I think it's the
office is the the Christmas one is funny
but I feel like it's kind of the usual
antics of the office staff but just at
Christmas time I think that Michael
Scott has the same kind of moments
across many different episodes and dalon
Abby is said at Christmas but I think
that mine uh first of all I think could
be viewed almost independently of the
rest of the TV series as its own kind of
special little block of an episode and
also I just think that that it is so
much of the plot revoles specifically
about the emotions that we go through at
Christmas buying gift for somebody
trying to find the right one remembering
people and trying to carry their memory
on and I think it just specifically
connects to a lot of the emotions both
you guys are talking gifts here see it's
not about all gift giving you got your
final points all right Ken help me out
over there hey uh factually pretty clean
what culture ran a top 10 list of uh TV
Christmas episodes uh the office us
version came in at number four the other
two mentioned here not on that list for
the record the UK Christ special was
listed number one on that list a lot of
people tweeting in real screen 88 says
he's watching from Glasgow loves the
show in my opinion the best Christmas
episode is the one with the holiday
armadillo from friends a lot of people
call for that Chris Evans talks about
festives for the rest of us from
Seinfeld Chris doctor uh
WAP am Amura 92 I don't think it's the
same one thanks for tuning in Chris yeah
he might be in Civil War though redclaw
redclaw 87 says Doctor Who's Christmas
specials are amazing every year and a
lot of love for abed's uncontrollable
Christmas from community and Scott
McFarland uh scottm on Twitter says
never thought I'd hear Jason Muse
talking about downon Abby Jason you're
expanding your reach here today you wow
a really good fight guys I think that
you guys kind of made a similar point
across the board which that each of your
episodes had a little bit of diversity
in it made you laugh made you cry had
moments you could relate to uh but the
person whose argument stood out to me
the most talked about the specifics of
it being personally connecting to them
so there was passion there it being
uplifting there being romance but it
also being deep and serious uh and that
would be Dan so Dan you get the point
Thank You K know's out of little tricks
to be like it meant a lot to me and open
my heart made me smile he knows how to
fight he's not a virgin on this he knows
all right guys here we go round
two there's a lot of them out there so I
so glad that this question got got
tweeted in by one of our fans who has
watched every episode has been
absolutely amazing at Nick leftover
wants to know who is the worst TV mom
starting with Jason going to Dan and
then Rob Moira Queen from uh arrow is my
worst mom I mean I think for here for
one she killed her husband uh almost
killed her son she blew up uh the city
with this earthquake machine well she
didn't do it herself but she was part of
that so she killed hundreds and hundreds
of people so I mean that's just a little
tidbit right there okay Dan my choice is
Lucille Bluth from Arrested Development
Lucille Bluth is a monster she despises
her children she manipulates and turns
them against each other not only did she
have three biological children she then
adopted two more that she went on to
warp as well so because of the complete
lack of respect and utter outright
contempt for her own children I'm going
with Lucille Bluth okay Rob all right
and my choice is uh Gemma T Maro who is
played by Seagal on Sons of Anarchy uh
she is a rather horrible mom and while a
lot of what she does comes out of a
place of being somewhat obsessed with
her son it leads her to eventually uh
murder the love of her son's life all
right spoiler alert Moira Lucille and
Gemma let's
fight so I'm first huh so I think MOA
Queen's the the worse because she again
she blew up uh her husband's boat and
almost killed her son um was part of
taking down half this city um then she
was running for mayor to try to redeem
herself um and just just was rotten she
paid off um Oliver's a girl he was
dating and who got pregnant um and so he
missed out on many many years of his
son's life spoiler alert uh for people
who haven't watched but yes he has a son
and he doesn't know until later on and
so yeah he missed that on many many
years that so those are just U some
tidbits of why I think she's
awful I mean I think the the measure of
a mother is how they treat their
children and let's break it down she has
Buster who she's lied to about his
actual father for his entire life she's
got job who in the pilot literally she
says I don't care for job so she doesn't
like him she has Michael who she only
pays attention to when she needs
something from him and uh if she says
that she loves him it's because she's
trying to manipulate him usually against
his other siblings then she's got the
adopted daughter Lindsay who she drove
to to an eating disorder and plastic
surgery by the way she adopted her out
of spite to uh piss off one of her
enemies and then she has anang her
Korean adopted child who she again
adopts out of spite to spite her other
children and abandons as soon as he's
outlived his usefulness but Lucille
loves Buster so much that they compete
in competitions together of mother boy
competitions I mean that has to account
for some goodness and how many murders
does Lucille have under her belt well I
mean the kids that in general is a a
sign of goodness she adopted them put a
roof over their head right and she's
feeding them yeah so she's not that bad
you could say that that buster being so
attached to his mother is a product of
love I say it's a product of him of her
twisting his mind I mean she has broken
that man irredeemably and she keeps him
under her thumb unless she doesn't need
him and then she shoves him aside she
she toys with him she's cruel she's
extraordinarily cruel to him and again
it's like I don't think she cares for
any of these children while she is
certainly a bad mom I believe Gemma is
the worst of these moms that not only uh
did she ultimately uh kill the uh kill
Tara the love of Jack's life with a fork
in like the back of her head in Cold
Blood and then tried to cover up the
Murder Jack wouldn't wouldn't find that
out that was sort of an accident they
were fighting they were fighting it
wasn't wasn't premeditated it wasn't it
wasn't premeditated Queen had
premeditation there across the
Gemma premeditated the murder of JT JT
teller and then married clay and then
brought Jackson to have to have his
stepfather be the guy who was part of
the murder of his father and then brings
him into this horrible life in the Sons
of Anarchy well again here Moira killed
her husband she killed her husband but
she almost killed her own son did Jimma
only ever almost kill Jax no she loves
Jax too much she did a lot of things
that ultim
some hot water
yeah yeah it sounds like there's it
sounds like a lot of terrible acts that
are committed perhaps out of a misguided
love for your children terrible acts
nonetheless and I feel like there's some
accidental acts she certainly does not
seem like a very nice person yes right
talking about I agree again and mor
morio certainly seems like a
megalomaniac who's out to get power but
you know I haven't I haven't heard of
many bad things that she's done directly
to her son well she hasn't raised either
one of her kids really because she pays
them off she don't punish them there's
few episodes where they talk about like
the girl gets drunken and driving the
daughter she just lets her you know pays
for her to get out of jail and stuff so
she's not really raising them either
she's not really taking care of them
she's all about power so but definitely
I don't think your mom's in the running
because again as awful as she might be
to each one of those children she still
adopted them so to me putting a roof
over someone's house and feeding them
that's a little bit of kindness right
there well she adopted and tortured them
to be fair and neglected them how much
torture they like
not it's the worst kind of torture
long-term psychological torture it's a
very scarring thing well if you could
see them all as adults when they grow up
if if they're scarred for life then
maybe we could talk about it but who
knows they could one could become a
president the other one could become
president Ona
yes hi Ken in the blanky hat what's
going on over there as someone pointed
out on Twitter it's the Infinity Stones
in my hat right now yes uh Hey Lucille
Boo Here Bluth here's some money go see
a star war one of my favorite CLS I use
in Day Life uh factually pretty clean a
lot of people on Twitter saying uh how
come no one picked Harriet Winslow one
of her kids went missing she didn't even
look for from Thomas uh Danny says
Lucille Bluth boo Bluth for sure but
also mallerie Archer also same actress
there G A Carelli says these are three
amazing choices Moira moir Queen is
definitely the worst she help destroy an
entire city and her family and David
Oaks at David oxs 8 says what about
Cersei Lannister one of the most hated
characters plus she pushed out Joffrey
spawn of the devil and I hope to make
Cersei my ex-wife one day as well I
thought about Cersei she's actually not
a bad mother she's a Terri person but
not a bad mother she loves her children
very much fair point Fair Point these
are three horrible moms and three shows
that I love so much and never really
looked at them this way so it's
interesting but here when you guys went
to Dan I thought that he was on to
something but when you guys talked about
your people are murdering people left
and right so Dan's mom ends up not
seeming that dad and by Dan's mom I mean
Lucio my mom is a saint by the way so I
I think that that kind of knocked him
out of the argument because yeah he you
even said he's adopting people like get
putting roofs over their heads so you
know Dan got knocked out it was between
Jason and Rob here uh both murdering
mothers but I feel like the person who
made the point of why they were a bad
mom more so than why they were a bad
person actually was Jason because he
talked about all those final things at
the end there with um what what Moira
did pay trying to pay them off not being
there for them and almost killing her
own child so Jason gets his point yay
yeah all
right it was a close one though guys
close was close three terrible mothers
let's just be glad that none of those
were our moms I'm happy for that okay
round
three it's the end of the year so we
have to ask this question it's a huge
question to ask you guys though so I'm
very excited to hear you guys fight this
it's what is the best show of 2015
starting with Dan going to Rob and then
Jason so much to choose from I almost
went with Fargo which I loved this year
but I ended up going way back to the
beginning of this year to a show that I
think a lot of people might have
forgotten was at the beginning of this
year I went with the Jinx on HBO uh the
Jinx was the most addictive show that I
watched uh this entire year i i i i k
picked up on it about six episodes in I
immediately binged all of the available
episodes and then waited every week with
holding my breath to see what would
happen next Robert Durst is a better
real life character than anyone could
write if somebody wrote that character
they'd say that that you were being uh
uh too outlandish and I'll talk about it
more but the Jinx for me was the
must-watch TV show of 2015 uh for me I
went with another HBO show uh the
leftovers which I first checked it out
last summer and I wasn't too into it and
people said no you got to go back and I
recently binge watch the entire series I
couldn't stop it was the best thing that
I had binged since breaking bad and it
is a show that really recreated itself
in its second season had an outstanding
second half of its run in the back half
of this season and I think it was the
best of the year in 2015 I picked the
flash um I don't know I mean there's
much to say but it's an awesome show I
mean the flash uh you know it's it's
they've did such a great job they've
done such a great job uh with taking it
a comic book character and bringing it
to TV and bringing all these different
uh you know villains and and different
characters into it and then they've done
a spin-off um you know that was a
spin-off of Arrow now they're doing a SP
spin-off of The Flash Legends of
Tomorrow they've they're doing like you
know one episodes on flash ones on Arrow
so the way they're just doing all these
shows and combining them and bringing in
different characters to me has been
they've done it flawlessly so all right
Jinx leftovers
flash I mean the thing that puts it over
the top is you to hear it's it's a
saying that been around forever truth is
Stranger Than Fiction and the this show
the Jinx was unlike anything I've ever
seen on television just the luck that
this crew had to be the fact like they
caught on camera the instant that a
murderer got caught in a lie and is and
that would have been great that would
have been enough but then they catch his
confession on camera like nothing like
that has ever happened in any television
show real or fictional ever made before
the Robert dur I just I I thought
halfway through it like this was some
kind of a prank like there's no way a
guy like this exists and and that nobody
has ever heard of him it was so unique
and so unlike anything I'd ever seen on
television before that it just blew me
away I feel like so I feel like it has
to be a certain taste for people though
I don't feel like everyone could enjoy
that I definitely think it it's it's
could be awesome but not for everybody
where the flash I feel like anyone can
enjoy adult kids it's all around amaz
awesome if you know Comics don't know
Comics it doesn't matter what I think
was so great about the leftovers it's
just the most emotional show on
television I mean once you start hearing
that music from The Leftovers when that
Max rter score comes up I mean you you
almost start crying it could be just
playing anywhere and the acting in this
show was so incredible uh all the
performances uh that that were in in the
season uh and the episodes just like the
the last couple of episodes and I don't
know if if you guys if you guys follow
the show the international Assassin
episode episode 8 of this season was one
of the best episodes of Television that
I've ever seen uh and it just is a show
that just kept topping itself week after
week and it was just a uh a it was an
emotional experience not just a TV
show uh but my right off the bat you
said that you watched it excuse me and
then you had to go back to watch it so
to me that is an
amazing that was last year amazing show
to me is you turn it on you watch the
episode and you can't stop watching an
episode and you got to see the next and
you got to see the next you don't have
to leave come back and someone's like
check it out I'm telling you you'll dig
it there's a bunch of shows I watch like
that where I watch the first three
episodes I'm like e and then I go back
and keep watching and it's awesome but
I'm just saying right there I feel like
that throws you over here and throws the
flash up here again a flash you could
either be a comic book lover and know
the character from years and years of
reading comics or you can just never
have seen a comic book or no comic books
and turn it on and enjoy it because you
know you got a kid whose mother passed
away it's sort of shaped his life then
he's got superpowers then you got people
from alternate universes and it's
awesome yeah my hitback Against The
Leftovers would be and and I have to be
honest I I don't watch it but one of the
reasons that I don't is I heard even
with this season I heard that it it came
on strong at the end but that the first
part of the season was a little it was
worth it it was worth it so it sounds
like it might be a bit of a mixed bag no
no mixed bag it was a it was a very it
was a straight bag a straight bag fair
fair enough and then uh flash I mean
yeah it's a really great fun show but I
I don't necessarily think that that best
uh equates with the most uh po populist
show you're right the Jinx won't connect
with everybody but I think when you're
talking best you're talking about
quality you're talking about just
Innovation and you're talking about um
just the Monumental nature of what
happens on the show and I just think the
Jinx what what puts me above a show that
I like and that I enjoy is the fact that
there's nothing quite like it that's
ever happened on television nothing has
unfolded that miraculously to be caught
on film fin from everybody I will I will
give you that that there was a great
moment in the Jinx but to me at just six
episodes I feel like the Jinx was more
of a miniseries and I feel like at 22
Episodes I feel like the flash is very
bloated and is uh is has too much filler
in there where the leftovers to me is
much more of the Goldilocks of the baby
bear in this scenar it is the just
perfect amount of episodes and did a
great job of telling this fantastic
story in its second season and not
everyone will agree with that because I
want more just like Game of Thrones I
Love Game of Thrones I would want 23
episodes I don't think there's filler in
there if I could watch 40 episodes I'd
watch 40 episodes so I don't think 23
episodes is making it bloated because a
good show you can sit and watch 23 13's
good for certain things if they're an
hour long or something but again I feel
like flash can appeal to everybody I
know what you're saying about it being
like there's but there's awesome for
like drama and then there's awesome for
comedy and then there's awesome uh you
know for different genres this is I feel
like again a genre that can shape for
everything there's a little bit of humor
a little bit of Awesomeness a little bit
of drama and all that stuff so you know
again I pick flashover Jinx and over
leftover so yeah and I think that the
Jinx is I hate how they're having to
subcategorize and subdivide television
now based on number of episodes well
that's not a series that's a miniseries
and that's for me it's all just in one
big Hopper and it's if you have six or
23 episodes It's a TV show and I'll kind
of Judge you on an even ke um and yeah
again like I say it's it's it's really
just I I The Flash is is fun I think for
for comic book fans and it has a little
bit of crossover appeal but I think
there's some people that the comic book
thing comic book shows just aren't their
thing which is fine and I think the Jinx
is much more of kind of a broader more
applicable thing of just like as far as
quality and uniqueness it kind of
transcends all of
that hey Ken how are the fat hey Roxy
here are the facts all clean we now
thanks to Rob C can Define good shows by
what we are now calling the Goldilocks
Theory
gold 10 episodes right in this day and
age of Mega shows on network TV and then
special shows on cable that makes some
sense lot of people obviously this is
our title fight today best TV show 2015
a lot of opinions our friend Langley M
Neely on Twitter says season one of
leftover ruins the idea of it being the
best show I hated season one with the
last year that was it's the worst of we
are talking ktie Rasmus and Andrew
laughes bull saying Jessica Jones John
Heaton says Jason wins this one flash is
awesome Grant Gustin rocks uh Christian
El ellias says uh Mr Robot comic book
nerd says House of Cards Craig Norris
says narcos our very own producer Liz
bonset keeps whispering in my ear
Homeland Homeland Homeland so there's a
lot of choices big round you guys
brought today with some great choices I
could have picked five show I was say
home but Homeland started like three
years ago right was it did it matter on
the but Homeland didn't it was just the
best show 2015 of this season fair
enough you guys happened to pick my
three the shows that I think are the
three best shows of 2015 I I have seen
every single episode of all three of
these shows and I think they're amazing
so I have to put my feelings aside on
this one and go with the facts the
arguments and the passion that was
presented to me um I think that when you
guys I I negate the fight that leftovers
wasn't good season one so that this
doesn't count that's not true uh if
we're talking about it in 2015 that
being said I feel like rob you fought
for one episode more than you fought for
the whole season as you talked about
internal International assassin being
one of the best episodes but none of the
other episodes were mentioned and when
they said that earlier on in the season
it wasn't that good you said it was a
straight bag but I needed to hear more
about the entire season so it ended up
being between Dan and Jason on this one
uh and I think that Jason made really
good points about how this is an
incredible comic book show uh but
everybody can love it but then Dan said
the best doesn't necessarily mean that
everybody can love it and he talked
about a show that was the best because
of the character uh the strength in that
character how we've never seen anything
like it and I agree that it the
question's best show not best series of
a certain number of episodes so Dan you
get the point on this one all right that
was like soie choice for me and I don't
know how I don't know how I'm going to
recover from this I was likeo a baby
that was sad okay here we go round
four this is coming from you guys on
Twitter thanks so much for tweeting
these in using the hash TV fights is
from K Davis 817 since they always seem
to last for many seasons what is the
best TV show based in a hospital
starting with Rob going to Jason and
then Dan well I think this is a pretty
straightforward question I think that
the answer is the Juggernaut in this
category which is e are a show that
really just had this amazing run at the
height of its popularity uh they had
episodes where over 40 million people
are watching it they had Seasons where
they were averaging over 30 million
people that were watching it they lost
people the show didn't miss a beat I
think ER is
unquestionably the greatest Hospital
show of all time i' would say Gray's
Anatomy for me uh Gray's Anatomy because
uh you know you got gray whose whose
mother was uh you know and she won all
these Awards and then she's there as an
intern they do four SE like three
seasons of them being interns and they
become uh you know into the doctors and
so on and so forth and it grows and then
there's the Love Story involved and then
there's people who fall in love with
some patience I just feel like all
around it just kept going and I really
dig it so that's why I think it's the
best I guess I explain more I mean I
think there's probably three the three
big answers to this would be ER gra
anatomy and my choice which would be
some who might say house I say scrubs uh
and the reason that I say scrubs is
because uh I think the problem that I
have with a lot of hospital dramas is
that they do stick around for many many
seasons and so it becomes kind of a
revolving door and and me just my
personal preference is I always like to
delve deep into characters and and and
learn more about them and I feel like
the characters kind of cycle in and out
of a lot of those shows so the reason
why I said scrubs is that they stuck
with the except for the very very end
they St with the same basic core of
characters and and everything kind of
revolved around how it affected them and
it wasn't so much drama for drama's sake
it was very much connected to how is
this experience ining you know uh Turks
or JD's experience as a doctor and it
was less like oh here's the big episode
of the week there's a huge crash and
it's more like how how is what's going
to happen this week aside from being a
comedy going to affect them personally I
think it's a little more based on the
characters got the three big dogs in
this fight ER gra anatomy and scrub
let's hear it guys well in terms of ER I
mean I feel like that it is beyond even
the genre of J Hospital show I mean if
we were talking about the history of the
greatest broadcast dramas of all time I
feel like that ER has to be up there in
that conversation and while Gres Anatomy
is fun I'm not sure if that is
necessarily one of the all-time great
Network dramas and scrubs I'm not sure
if it's one of the all-time great
Network comedies even whereas ER is is
just is just I feel like Head and
Shoulders about these other
shows uh I don't know I mean I that
Gray's you know again he was saying that
the the same character
Stu test and move on and then like one
of the characters George didn't move on
um you know it has then just then
there's MC steamy and MC dreamy and the
the the love affair there and he passes
away later on and and uh just the
challenge of twoo is the characters were
like the one uh Yang she you know she
was in love with one of the doctors and
he wanted to have a family but she
didn't because cuz she was all about
wanting to be a doctor so I feel like
there was drama there was comedy in
there and there was a there was a couple
love stories um and it you know it's
still going it's still running uh you
know 12 Seasons later and I feel like
again I think you can really relate with
a bunch of the characters and get to
know a bunch of the characters and some
of them you can't but that's my argument
on the fact um I I think ER has been I
call it simpsonized a little bit which
is that the first six seasons were some
of the best uh drama seasons ever but
the problem is that it hung around for
like eight more seasons I remember when
it finally ended like I watched that
show in high school and I remember
seeing an ad on NBC it's like the series
finale of ER and I lived out here I was
like still on I so I think that it it it
it started out very strong but it it
stayed around too long and I think it
kind of got forgotten scub time goes on
well that's you know listen as you said
many of these stuck around for many many
seasons I think scrubs at the end was
still about the core characters whereas
like like I said I watched the series
finale of and I didn't know any of these
people I was like who are I know I know
none of these people I had nothing in
common with the show that I remembered
watching and and I think that scrub
still had those those characters and
then with gry's Anatomy it just comes
down to personal preference I think it's
it's the same reason I can't get into
soap operas I just think it's a little
soapy and I prefer not quite that much
but let's not judge these things
necessarily by where they ultimately got
off because all of these shows get kind
of messy by the end I think we need to
look at where were they in their highest
highs and I think that ER still has the
highest highs of any of these shows and
was able to sustain the losses of so
many of the characters where Grey's
Anatomy never had to lose Meredith and
it's turned out where like Meredith gray
has had like the worst life of any human
being ever like everybody that she knows
has had some terrible tragedy or has
died or I mean it's horrible you
wouldn't wish this life on anybody you
wouldn't I guess you wouldn't but again
she she's uh she's made it through and
she's still there she's still a doctor
she's still taking care of her children
even though she lost her husand husband
she uh lost her mother and she works
with uh you know the the man who said I
get to sit around and watch it with the
wife and we both can enjoy it um and
there's not many shows I can sit around
I can't watch The Flash or any of these
other shows with the wife so for me
again I think there's a little bit of
everything in there and I was able to uh
and I think it's a good show it's a good
soap opery Hospital show where scrubs is
more comedy isn't is based on two guys
mainly the two M definitely more of
Comedy again I mean I I don't know so
it's more comedy very dramatic and then
you got mine which is in the middle
there you get a little soap opery drama
comedy and all that business love
stories you got MC mcam and MC stami in
there come on and there was a spin-off
made of it there's the you know uh the
wife of McDreamy came on the show for a
few seasons and then went off and did a
separate so called Private Practice any
show that you can do a spin-off of is
King okay final points from you up
I just feel like that ER I mean it
launched uh so many careers out of that
show again it was such a juggernaut in
the 90s it premiered in the fall of 94
very good uh fall of '94 on NBC between
ER and friends coming on at that point
in time and I feel like that it really
was a game changer for NBC for 15 years
okay Dan final Point um yeah I mean it's
I think Rob you're right I think all of
these shows outlasted their welcome to
to more or less of an extent the reason
I'm going with why I put it a little bit
over is just because of the continuity
because it stayed true to the core of
the characters Up Until the End whereas
I think the other ones you kind of lose
a little bit of that as time went on
okay hey Ken what's up with those facts
they're all pretty clean a lot of it uh
uh you
know I think coming into this we all had
a certain view of Jason muse from his
wonderful work with the the movies but
now we know him as a man who likes to
curl up under her blanket watch downtown
ABY and gra an we're learning a new side
te you sir it's great a lot of of people
out there loving scrubs Yosi bman says
scrubs no question uh trajan the great
says got to be scrubs JT and Turk of the
best love story on TV Patricia kill's
house which a lot of people wanted house
to be represented uh our friend Perkins
Kadeem Perkin says Ken I say kadim best
TV show based in Hospital's house uh
he's in there too scrubs a lot of votes
for scrubs and house Chris zman says
let's be real Mash is basically a
hospital show too that comass his great
comedy and emotional dramatic moments I
didn't even think about that I almost
cynically answered Mash but I've never
seen it and I didn't want to just be
like oh yeah Mash is one of the greatest
TV shows ever F yeah never seen it I
don't want to fake it uh so I I agree
with the chat that scrubs is a great
show but I think that I didn't hear
enough specifics from you Dan they they
talked about JT and Kirk JD and Kirk and
all the uh JD and Turk what I just call
them JT andk it's funny because I've
seen every single episode of every one
of these shows too it all gets lost in
my brain somewhere but um I didn't hear
the specifics about like you said it got
bad towards the end but it was
character-based I wanted to know more
more about why it was the best so it was
between Rob and Jason on this one uh and
then I had to hear you guys also say
that both of these shows kind of trailed
off a little bit towards the end what
really got me was the final point that
Rob made though about this launching
careers I was waiting for you to say it
when talking about ER it's a really
Point important point to make so if you
hadn't made it I think it was going to
go to Jason but that final Point really
stuck it launched careers
Rob gets his point all right and you're
not going to change your mind like some
Steve Harvey
thing I haven't put a crown on your head
yet so you know we should have a crown
on the show may be well you can use the
Christmas hat but I want that how about
we take his with the infinity stone yes
I'm gladly auction it off at the end of
this one of you will get the crystal
stone infinity stone hat it will be
great here we go for round
five from uh at Travis of Marvel another
Twitter question thank you wants to know
what TV show home or apartment would you
want to live in really fun question
starting with Jason going to Dan and
then Rob uh I picked uh mine's Lex
Luther's house in Smallville I mean he
lived in this awesome huge castle that
was brought over from Ireland Stone by
Stone uh you know there was secret
passages and and he just had all these
awesome rooms uh and it's humongous and
the property itself was was pretty sweet
so
Dam there was only one answer for me and
it was a big part of my childhood was
the place that I always wanted to go and
that is peewee's playhouse has a more
joyful place ever existed than peewee's
Playhouse you walk in the door all your
puppet friends are there you got a
dinosaur you got the chair what do you
want to do today let's jump in the magic
screen John B will grant you a wish
Cowboy Curtis will drop by King of
cartoons will show you a cartoon there's
never a dull moment it's happiness it is
pure unbridled happiness at peewee's
Playhouse and I want to go there okay
and I was somewhat practical about this
I really looked at the map of where I
wanted to live who had the nicest house
and I chose the Malibu beach house from
Two and a Half Men that uh that Charlie
and Allan live in the house is so nice
Charlie Sheen could not afford to live
in that house now that is how nice this
house is this beautiful mansion on the
Malibu Coast is that saying something
about Charlie or saying something about
the house I think it's saying something
that they the house has maintained its
value okay really strange fight here
between Lex Luther peewee's playoffs and
Two and a Half Men let's hear it guys uh
I would say you know what both of those
places sound great it's funny cuz
peewee's Playhouse popped into my head
for a second it would be cool but I feel
like I would get sick and tired of
walking in and being like Jason dud play
Jason's playing house um it would just
be too much and I don't think it could
work for everybody um for Malibu of
course living at the beach could be cool
but you know what if it's in Malibu
driving down the tent and trying to get
into to LA and stuff with traffic and
then if you know there's how's the
traffic from
Smallville you know what take a
helicopter you have that Mansion Lex has
a helicopter you could take that thing
there so again even if the beach isn't
even if the house isn't Malibu it's a
beautiful house um you're right but
again I feel like you have to want to be
living on the beach for it to all appeal
to that and I don't think everyone wants
to live at the water and at the beach
beautiful to live at the beach it is but
again I don't think everyone would want
that where I feel like everyone could
live on a big property in a castle and
who doesn't want secret passages how
many people died in that Lex Luther
house how many ghosts are wandering
around that house is it haunted can you
say definitively no it's no one died no
one actually died in that well you're
sorry there's a few enemies it has a
safe it has a safe room though a a Panic
Room if you will I mean who doesn't want
a pan bad things happen there you need a
panic room and they could happen at the
Malibu house and they could happen at
peewee's house even the chair could come
get mad and eat you Cherry would never
do that never know peewee's Playhouse is
terrifying to go there and with all
these things are are coming to life and
on top of it pe's Playhouse was cool
when we were little kids but if you have
an iPad 2 that is putting magic screen
to shame at this point it is it is not
Advanced with the time yes and it
depends if you're single you don't want
to like you bring a girl back to there
and you're like on the couch smooch and
all a sudden cherries like right you
know hitting her in the booty or
something distracting you it's not very
ideal because again I thought about it I
was like how awesome would it be to be
able to go down this slide and do this
and this but I think that would only be
a temporary uh fun like I disagree oh
your childhoods have died you
disagree first of all cherry Cherry's up
to a lot of bad things in your mind
Jason Cherry is so nice Cherry's very
pure Cherry would never do that you
could have a bad day though you never
know listen here's the thing
is if I hopefully if I work hard enough
maybe and and got with a little bit of
luck I could live in a mansion someday
that's a thing I can go to I can go
visit any number of mansions in a museum
you know you'll never you can never go
to anywhere like peewee's Playhouse how
could you get sick of it you're
surrounded by your friends all the time
everybody's no privacy everybody
everybody's happy the real world you
don't have to worry about the real world
webcaming might be webcaming
right and think about all the popins you
got Cowboy Curtis every 5 Seconds misson
oh now I got watch King of cartoons if
you want there's no way to turn it all
off I agree with that that's why again
it would be fun for a day but then you'd
get sick of it the beach house again I
feel like it's very nice but even then
it's very nice but again it's like it's
nice not it doesn't have any it's not
got charact it do character there's a
housekeeper and also Allan would never
wanted to leave that's how nice it was
but there's a lot of those houses man
you go down Malibu strip there is a lot
of houses on the
similar character to it Aion has
character it's brought over from another
another country I love it see I'm not a
I'm not a Hermit I don't want to go
someplace where no one's ever going to
bother me I certainly don't want to live
in Murder mansion and I don't want to
live anywhere where Charlie Sheen has
lived no than oh you think it's better
to live where PeeWee Herman has been
living get a black light in that
Playhouse oh my God Ken help me you're
on your own on this one first of all can
we hear the Jason's Playhouse theme song
again that was my
favorite
Jason we playing I don't even remember
great I remember what it wasow ctis got
mentioned of course famously Lawrence
Fishburn and a little fact about me two
for two straight birthdays my mother let
me redesign our living room as peewee's
Playhouse so I had many fun memories too
there Dan uh Matt stoker on Twitter at
stok tastic says better house and all
those suggestions the Jetson's home
which is a pretty good thing I would say
Belinda Rose says peewee's Playhouse I
always want to live in that house to Dan
you were not alone George cashion says
the Fresh Prince house that house has
everything everyone wants to go to a
mansion I'm going to steal one from Andy
this is tough this is a tough one uh I I
was pretty sold with Dan's peewee's
Playhouse until we started getting into
the logistics of not just visiting it
but actually living there every time
walking in with a song that point you
made and trying to be single living in
that house bringing any back or even if
you aren't single I I think you guys
made really good points and it got to be
a little creepy actually living there
all dead inside they made it feel
creepy and also living somewhere peew
lived and on that note then we had
living somewhere where Charlie had lived
in the blackl comment and I started to
question that house so now I'm not only
just thinking about the house I'm
thinking about their beds you guys are
weird um so I feel like the house that
had the that we couldn't necessarily
just live in it wasn't just a mansion
that maybe we could buy one day but the
one that talked about the secret
passages um and the helicopter so you
could get around all that the things
that come with this house that he
included the murder house I I think it's
got to be the murder house it's got to
go to Lex Luther so Jason you get the
point yes you're all dead
inside I don't I don't know if that's
true Dan we'll go H hang with John be
the genie all right
you okay here we go here we go with the
round
six this is another Twitter question
coming from kadem Perkins which 2016 TV
show are you most anticipating so what
are you guys most excited about in 2016
starting with Dan then Rob and then
Jason there were a lot of again a lot of
choices the one that the one that I went
with is the one that that I'm not only
anticipating that intrigues me the most
is American Crime Story which we're
starting to see a lot of trailers for
which the first season is going to be
the people versus OJ Simpson because uh
I think that like this was like the OJ
trial was like the dawn of modern day
reality television is like people were
watching that thing nonstop for like a
year straight but all you saw was what
happened in front of the camera you all
you saw was what happened in the
courtroom and here we're going to get
like this look at what happened behind
the scenes you got the Cuba ging Jr you
got John Travolta you've got Sarah
Paulson you've got Nathan Lane you got
Courtney B Vance and Connie Briton and a
great cast and the fact that it's just
like I it's like I'm 90% sure this is
going to be a great TV show and I'm 10%
sure this is going to be a massive train
wreck but either way I cannot wait to
see it okay Rob all right I'm going with
uh season six of Game of Thrones perhaps
the most highly anticipated TV season of
all time uh that there's H so much
Intrigue uh surrounding Jon Snow and how
that situation is going to be resolved I
think that uh everybody is going to be
talking about that that weekend in April
when that's going to be premiering it's
going to be similar like this past week
with the Star Wars opening it's just
going to be Game of Thrones everywhere I
think that's the most anticipated TV
show by far
uh I say Legends of tomorrow um I think
uh again it's something new it's fresh
um again it's spun off of the the arrow
and the Flash um and they're bringing
all the different characters don't get
me wrong I'm a huge fan of Game of
Thrones I'm very excited about that but
again it's season six like this is
something new and and fresh to me that's
a a whole new start of a new show his we
his show um again I think it's got to be
taste you want to sit and watch all
about someone's buildup to their murder
um you know and then next it'll be John
Wayne bobit where they're showing him
you know do you want to watch a woman
cut someone's wiener off uh again this
is what I feel like these Crime Story
show will be about again I'm in the
crime style like I love me Law and Order
and CSI and all this stuff but this
seems like it's it's got to be a certain
taste for that crime drama thing so
anyway oh yeah I mean listen I'm not
saying american crime stories for
everybody this is a a very much a
personal preference for me because I was
12 13 14 years old when this all
happened so it was both the one thing I
couldn't get away from but I also didn't
really understand a lot of it so I am
personally very interested in finding
out some of the details of what actually
happened and Beyond just what I could
kind of comprehend at the time uh with
Game of Thrones I'm very torn I would
say I'm more nervous about it than I am
anticipating it because I think most
people generally would acknowledge that
season 5 was probably the I'm not saying
it was bad but was probably the weakest
season of Game of Thrones thus far and
we are approach we have approached we've
hit the point where we are off the rail
so to speak of George R Martin's Source
material so I think it's much more of an
X Factor of like what are we going to
get cuz now for the first time we really
don't know and combined with the little
bit of a Dro in quality it took last
season I'm a little less like like oh I
can't wait to see it and I'm like oh I'm
not sure I'm worried to me this is the
first time that we don't know what's
going to happen whereas the OJ Simpson
Saga that was like the first five
seasons of Game of Thrones that the
people who read the books know exactly
what's going to happen in the OJ
Simpsons Saga we were all there we've
all read the books we're all spoiled on
OJ whereas this season of Game of
Thrones this is the first time Anything
could happen all these people that uh
that read the books they don't know
what's going to happen anything could
happen and this is for the first time
ever like you think you saw those videos
of people watching the Red Wedding and
then they're like oh my God and because
people knew it was coming this time
everybody's blindsided nobody knows
what's coming and that's what makes this
season of Game of Thrones so special I
think I I mean again I agree with the
The Game of Thrones thing because again
I'm very I'm excited about it but it
like he said I'm very nervous about it
because again who knows what happened to
johon snow it's and and again I feel
like it can be very disappointing
because again if if he's gone people are
going to be bummed but also again reason
why I'm picking Legends of tomorrow
because again it's something uh that's
just the first season so you get to see
all these different characters um which
people would say people love if they
watch Flash and arrow um and you're
going to meet new characters they're
send they're bringing in vixon and
different other characters um and again
it's just fun and it's superheroes and
your kids can watch it and adults can
watch it and it's something new where
again Game of Thrones is awesome but
it's going to be disappointing or it's
going to be good and again it's already
been going so and again the crime J I
agree with you where where OJ and stuff
it's this season's about OJ um you know
you can read up I know you don't know
everything about the story you said and
it will show you but you could read up
on it and all that stuff so I I don't
think you know it's not going to it's
going to be cool and interesting to to
see it like liveaction OJ's story but
you can read up on it and read the news
and read books and stories and and and
all the different K Caitlyn and such so
and I mean you can probably tell from my
support of the Jinx is that this is just
a this is just a genre that I'm
attracted to uh True Crime and stuff
like that really really really
fascinates me and yes you can read about
it but a lot of the things that make it
interesting is you take events you know
the ending of it but you take the events
of it and you dramatize it and you make
them interesting and you make them
dramatic and compelling yes you know how
it you know the ending but it's more
like how you get there and I think the
combination of the guys that are behind
it which is Scott Alexander and Larry I
think it's kvy they both they wrote man
on the moon and Ed Wood you've got Ryan
Murphy on as an executive producer it's
I think a dramatization of events if
it's giving you information you don't
know can be just as interesting as as an
original series one of the turnoff for
me on this OJ thing is that it is
Kardashian adjacent where one of the big
things that they're buzzing about is
that OJ had a gun in Kim Kardashian's
room and so that it's going to be folded
into all of the Kardashian Echo chamber
and that is a that is a flaw for me well
I mean her dad was one of his attorneys
so it was bound to have some kind of a
connection to
it hey Ken talk to me about the facts uh
facts are pretty clean except for K kin
was the name I think K Caitlyn was what
Jason said but I think that's a new
character in some Marvel
show
SP it out man
fast it's a new character and I love
that Rob SE threw the term blindsided in
there cuz some it's a life he's had to
live Amy awesome not a fan of Game of
Thrones but she is looking forward to
Twin Peaks on Showtime Karen at Karen
the wck love that name uh is like me
anticipating It's Always Sunny in
Philadelphia uh August F Schmid says
Game of Thrones which I too am highly
anticipating especially now that they no
longer have the books to guide them and
Trevor Baston is excited for Luke Cage
Brian Knight excited for West World
there is a lot of shows coming out in
201 vinyl one I'm looking forward to as
well me too 2016 is going to be a really
great year and I'm going to watch all of
these shows uh Jason you were talking
about how new and fresh this was going
to be uh and I I felt like those were
the main points you were making which
were good but just not strong enough in
this argument with Dan and Rob so it
fell between you guys with two incred
very different shows uh but the question
was which show are you most anticipating
and I feel like that has to do with
passion a lot and it stuck with me from
the very beginning when Dan said this is
90% chance it's going to be great 10%
chance going to be a train wreck but
he's still anticipating either way how
what's more passionate than if you're
going to watch the show whether it's
great or horrible so that point sold me
very early plus then he mentioned the
minds behind the making of it so Dan you
get the point on this one ding ding ding
ding ding I think you should tweet that
at them I'm going to watch you even if
you're a train wreck I will watch it
even if it's a train wreck all right so
here we are going into the speed rounds
we've got Jason versus Dan and Rob I'm
going to be looking to you to help me
out uh cuz these get really intense and
I need you're you're my second judge
here you're willing and ready Ken I'm
going to be looking to you for a little
bit of help also hope that's all right
yes ma'am we all set over there we are
okay here we go see if I can do better
against Jay than I did against Kevin so
I'm going to say the question you guys
both you guys both will give an answer
whoever says the answer first gets to
start the second person goes second 15
seconds each and then 5sec rebuttal does
everybody understand the rules yes great
here we
go what is the best TV character or
actor named George George
Clooney okay George Clooney George wait
best actor or or character named George
George Carlin George Clooney versus
George Carlin starting with you Dan
people forget that before he was George
Clooney the movie star he was George
Clooney the TV star and he was the
biggest star on television star of Rob's
favorite medical drama ER uh like I say
he's such a mega Global Superstar now
that people forget that he started in TV
and that launched him start he's George
col is's awesome but George Carlin he's
a legend that's all I have to say he's a
legend he'll always be a legend I agree
that Carlin is a legend uh I know him
less from his work on television I I
know cloney he started on television
that's what kind of made the distinction
for me oh fair enough the television
fair enough for the I mean I guess she
yeah I'm going with that cuz again
George hasn't necessarily been on he's
been on HBO specials here we go
definitely a Legend um I my thoughts on
this one are that him being a legend is
true but I think that Dan gave more
points about what Clooney has done and
him being on your favorite show ER so
Rob what do you think yeah I think that
Dan made a stronger case while I don't
think anybody's contesting that George
Carlin is a legend I think that the the
case was made better by Dan all right
uh absolutely though Carlin did star on
some TV shows in the later of his career
and did make his mic there I think Dan
made the case for Clooney all right
we're giving that point to Dan all right
it's true it's true next question which
channel has better animated shows Adult
Swim or Fox Adult Swim no
Fox Okay starting with you Jason with
Adult
Swim I don't even know I don't even know
what cartoon Adult Swim I know has it's
all about cartoons uh right it started
off as animation and that's all they
play so I feel like they have a lot a
lot more uh awesome adultlike
cartoons uh fox has right now has I mean
Adult Swim has a lot of uh you know kind
of Niche cartoons but fox has the big
boys it's got Bob's Bergers it's got The
Simpsons it's got Family Guy uh you know
those are the names in animated comedy
right
now uh adults again but but yeah
you D I don't like this I don't like
this at all I can't even yeah I can't
argue with I mean ding Dan's
Counterpoint that uh lose guys it's a
great time for animation that's all I
got to say no matter where it is okay
all right um I think that Adult Swim
does play a lot of great cartoons which
you said but uh I think that Dan made
named the specifics rob you yep all
right so he was more specific I'll say
that so we'll give this point to
Dan next
question what is the best TV show with
the word day in the title
day Days of Our Lives oh that's a good
one uh
day Happy Days okay uh Days of our Liv's
been around for ever it's uh it's soap
opera I mean people have been tuning in
for many many many years people love the
back and forth and love and the this so
days Days of Our
Lives before it jumped the shark which
was it was Happy Days was so good that
uh even when it got bad it still turned
a cultural term for it but you got the
fond that had some of the best
characters of all time Ron Howard you
had Mor was introduced so many spin-offs
L Veron Shirley came out for that show
it was such a hit show for so long Days
of Our Lives had so many actors in it
that they keep revolving back and forth
and they've been working for 30 40 years
now both long live shows but I think
happy days has a more of a of a cultural
impact Days of Our Lives has been around
for a while Rob what are you thinking on
well I believe Jason himself said if a
show gets a spin-off from the show it
means that that show was great and so I
think by that logic I think he sort of
uh cornered himself well based on the
arguments that were presented here
though I feel like that that I would
give it to Dan okay what do you think
Ken
yeah I would go with Dan days of lives
is a great choice and it's a great
legacy and I think Jason did tap into
that uh I think Dan gave me some more
facts as why happy day stands out is the
best one tied to that name day yeah even
question even though he did say it jump
the shark he talked about The Fawns and
and named the more specific things so
I'm giving this one to Dan also that
would be and it and that means that
officially Dan you are not only a movie
fights champ but right now you're a TV
fights champ oh dear you guys put up a
really good fight though congratulations
to all you guys really good job uh that
that was awesome gets really intense
there at the end I like get sweaty for
you guys so I I feel you on that this
you've unified the titles oh no not
quite I think I'd have to run through a
much many more gauntlets to get the TV
fights title well the good news is we're
going to get to talk about all of this
and more after this on it after the
fights which you guys have to sign up to
for screen junkies Plus in order to
watch so we're going to get you guys a
chance to Skype in phone call if you
want to talk to these people at the
table or me or whatever it is Ken about
the fights we would love to hear we're
going to break down what exactly
happened here today but you have to be a
screen junkies plus member so go sign up
for screen junkies plus and we'll be
doing that right after this in 10
minutes from now guys amazing job thank
you so much for joining us here today I
want the people to know where they can
find you because you did such an awesome
job Rob where can everybody keep up with
you sure you can uh see all of my
podcasts at
robaz a website.com you can follow me on
Twitter robs Nino or for my scripted TV
podcast or on postshow raps.com cool
Jason uh
cmsm o.com that's uh M and Kevin's
website where we do all our touring and
stuff uh juse J yme WS is my Instagram
and my Twitter and all that fun stuff
awesome and Dan at meral Dan on Twitter
this was so much fun I've been a
Survivor Watcher since day one and Rob
was always one of my favorites on the Jo
and I told Kevin this when on movie
fights was that you guys' movies were a
huge part of my development years uh so
it was a pleasure fighting both you guys
as a real real thrill for me I'm with
you on both of those things really great
I'm so happy that we got to have you
guys at the table today and that we got
to have Ken Napo as our fact Checker
thank you as always Ken absolutely it's
nice to know that Kevin and Jay are to
blame for Dan's uh problems in my they
shaped me Ken they're not to blame they
shaped me look at that and he won he's
been winning all these fights
that's true yeah thanks we'll see you
guys in after the fight # after the
fight to join that conversation there
too very cool and you guys know that we
are here on screen junkies plus Tuesdays
at 400m live happy holidays to everybody
I'm Roxy strike find me at Roxy strier
until next
time take
[Applause]
[Music]
care